welcome to this video playing in Moscow
Rita big whale Mosca mascara okay so
what do we have
cannot print 93 even though I will play
it in most cases Spencer why they have
for those must be 6d 4 or 94 that's the
question
okay I'll go with d3
rook e8 looks like he wants to push me
five no C 5 actually it is a bit slower
c6 and c5 but the resulting structure
definitely looks ok for like interesting
plane ok vatic here it looks a little
bit like some reversed double V&K no my
takes with the bishop ok I stop guessing
Musa
I never guess any move right of the slim
so might as well just play stuff and
hope hope to be ok
hey I guess to move right boo
okay so he and the week square is
interesting on c6 maybe I can play for
that
the half-open if Alice use for him I
don't think is this as much but hmm it's
a bit annoying night coming to c6 and I
don't really want to play it with the
Queen trade best would be f4 pawn to f4
and then put the knight on c6 okay here
no Knight takes rook Kings right it's
just a bit annoying for blacks um let's
do it
maybe I had 97 actually probably not
okay and what to do here Bishop e5 is a
move that forces rook d7
I'm not sure that this helps much so
let's try to give the Snyder good
protection b5 Bishop b5 b7 95 should be
good for one for later
Luke c7
[Music]
I have to pay attention to the bishop
being unprotected here but there could
be discoveries so Knights 6 here and
maybe it doesn't threaten that much
Bishop tea for the soup d6 that is wrong
I am just covering this and go from
there
don't see yeah okay
I am okay - yeah okay so the rook d7
move was quite unsuccessful
no it's still not easy for Blackie I
believe but it isn't worse so much worse
Oh didn't expect this one okay but after
taking it's not okay it's got the e-file
[Music]
interesting
no blender the frickin before poornam
completely completely unnecessary him
from such a time learning a stick
position okay yeah I definitely had
something that I know that would have
put huge problems out for black
absolutely certain
threatening 96 winning no 97 is a
counter idea check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check na miscounted widow came well oh
my god that should have been such a nice
win iam black being totally totally
outplayed him but that didn't didn't
finish it off knight c6 wins and now
that there there must have been some
wins Black's completely on the ropes him
96 I had threatens Bishop before ah I
didn't see that idea I'm threatening
just to trap the rook here that set/sets
immediately over e 7 hangs and Bishop
before over to t8 so it's still terrible
but knight c6 is much stronger I didn't
I didn't see that one rookie 6 yeah this
is a dead piece on b6 and that was bad
yeah here taking I wasn't I wasn't sure
about that him something like that still
looks good somehow but he's got the D
pawn it's still an advantage yeah and
this is I just blundered dead
oh whoops e6 would have been good still
and the funny thing is I think the way
it was played out of I shouldn't have
any problems check check check check
check check check check
yeah yeah white is better again she
probably just a bit more precision and
I'm winning is
[Music]
rook c6 chicky you had just the check
first in d2 and then I'm just winning
I'm just meeting the king and one ending
of course okay well I had six seconds
but yeah here this is just completely
easy when I win the two pawns now okay I
had no time it's also spent a little bit
too much time in that really good
position where you can play quicker okay
anyway thanks for watching